Google recently announced their self-driving
cars have been in 11 crashes ever?
Like… ever.
But, I've never been in a car accident so
does that make me better than them?
This week, the Associated Press reported Google's
self-driving cars were involved in 11 minor
crashes in six years.
Is that a lot?
Not according to Google.
They count it as a win that their cars have
driven 1 million automated miles of testing
in the six years they've been at it, and have
only had these few fender benders.
By comparison, the human population crashes
about 0.3 times for every 100,000 miles, (161,000
km) per driver according to the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration.
Wait a second ... So really, Google’s stats
aren’t that much better at 0.6 per 100,000!
So why are they spending so much money to
develop a self-driving car that doesn't seem
safer?
Because many non-fatal crashes go unreported,
so it’s very likely that point three crashes
per 100,000 miles isn’t even accurate.
On top of that, 94 percent of ALL crashes
EVER are caused by human failure.
We are the absolute worst at driving.
Cell phone bans don't reduce crashes, drunk
driving prohibitions, speed limits, and the
like don't stop drivers crashing; instead
fatalities are still in the tens of thousands
every year.
In fact, the reason there were collisions
with the self-driving cars at all was because
of driver frickin' error!
Sources say the car has been rear-ended mostly,
but it's also been sideswiped and hit by a
car that ran a red light or stop sign.
Since the crash specifics are secret, we can't
be certain, but Google says the car was never
at fault, and eight of those crashes were
on city streets.
If you buy their spin, then yes - the cars
probably ARE safer!
And private cars are just the tip of the iceberg.
We’re also gonna be seeing autonomous vehicles
in the commercial space.
Earlier this month, auto manufacturer Daimler
unveiled its self-driving semi-truck.
The "Inspiration Truck" can drive itself on
the highway, and only needs a human operator
in cities.
On top of that, they can network on the road
and drive in a caravan, getting improved gas
milage as a crew by taking advantage of the
slipstream of the truck in front of them.
Basically, only the truck in front has to
fully cut through the air, the rest "draft"
and get a mileage boost.
The Bureau of Transportation Statistics estimates
commercial freight logged 3.3 TRILLION ton-miles
in 2012, and trucks represented 38 percent
of that -- or 1.3 TRILLION miles.That’s
a lot of ground to cover for the Inspiration
Truck or other similar commercial trucks.
Aside from Google and Daimler, Audi and Nissan
have also developed self-driving cars.
Tesla announced the Model S will have autonomous
features within a few months.
So the future is pretty much here.
The National Highway Traffic Safety Administration
ranks self-driving vehicles, and both the
Google cars and the Inspiration Truck as "Level
3" autonomous vehicles; not unlike an airplane
on autopilot.
They can travel autonomously, but quote "The
driver is expected to be available for occasional
control… [given] sufficiently comfortable
transition time."
So the car can't just toss it to the driver
when someone jumps in front… but then who
is at fault?
If "driver" wasn't actually driving, and Google
programmed the thing; what happens?
At this point, no one knows.
California, Nevada, Michigan, Florida, and
Washington, D.C are the only places that license
for self-driving cars, so far, and there are
only 48 autonomous vehicles registered in
California; 23 of those are Google's.
In the end these laws are still SO new, and
the technology isn't entirely proven.
Driving a million autonomous miles is piddly
compared to the trillions travelled by truck
drivers in the U.S. alone.
What do you think?
Are you looking forward to a future where
you never have to drive yourself?
How about a future with cars powered by salt
water?
Julian has more on that in
this video.